The world of "One Piece" is finally coming
to live-action in the form of a Netflix television show.
But who's behind bringing this worldwide phenomenon
to life?
Here's what you need to know before you watch
Netflix's "One Piece."
News of an American-made, live-action "One
Piece" TV show dates back to July 2017.
This was when producer and self-professed
"One Piece" fan Marty Adelstein announced
that his company Tomorrow Studios had secured
a partnership with Shueisha and author Eiichiro
Oda to adapt "One Piece" into a live-action
TV series.
Oda later revealed that he actually entered
discussions about a live-action, English language
version of "One Piece" a year earlier in 2016,
so it's been a long time coming at this point.
"So what do you say?
Are you with me?"
Netflix officially picked up the series in
2020 and ordered a 10-episode first season
that was later reduced to eight, though production
faced lengthy delays during the COVID-19 pandemic.
Production picked up again during 2021 and
the series began filming in early 2022, though
no details on a release date were given at
that point.
Fans speculated that the show would drop at
some point in 2023, and they were correct
— as revealed at Netflix's Tudum event in
Brazil, we now know that all eight episodes
of "One Piece" Season 1 will premiere on August
31, 2023.
What's One Piece about?
"One Piece" takes place in a fictional world
not too dissimilar to our own, though much
of the planet's surface is covered by water.
The only continent is called the Red Line,
a narrow strip of land that goes all the way
around the globe.
Also circling the globe is the Grand Line,
a stretch of ocean that's known for its rapidly
changing weather and dangerous sea life.
When they cross, these two lines split a huge
body of water known as the Blue Sea into four
quadrants: the East Blue, the West Blue, the
North Blue, and the South Blue.
There are many, many islands in the Blue Sea,
some of them safer than others — this is
a world full of pirates, after all.
The story follows the Straw Hat pirates, named
after the hat worn by their optimistic captain
Monkey D. Luffy.
It's Luffy's dream to find the legendary treasure
known as the One Piece, which was hidden by
the famed pirate Gol D. Roger before his execution
at the hands of the World Government.
Whoever finds it will be proclaimed the new
Pirate King, and Luffy won't stop until that
title is his.
He knows he can't do this alone, however,
so he sets about putting a crew together and
making a name for himself.
This is all covered in the East Blue saga,
which — going by the promotional material
and casting news — is what the first season
of Netflix's "One Piece" will be based on.
The lead role of Monkey D. Luffy is being
played by a young actor named Iñaki Godoy,
building on a filmography that thus far consists
predominantly of projects made in his home
country of Mexico.
In an interview with Decider, Godoy revealed
that he started reading the manga and watching
the anime after winning his "One Piece" role,
mainly so he could get a grasp on Luffy's
bizarre physicality — after eating a Devil
Fruit, his body has the properties of rubber.
He said,
"How can I translate this rubber-man into
live action?
In those cases, I really used the anime and
manga for reference and I literally tried
to replicate the way this guy fights."
He continued in detail,
"When he throws a punch and he takes it back,
he puts his hand on his bicep or his shoulder.
So, if he does that, I should do that too,
right?
And when he's about to throw a punch, sometimes
he lifts up his leg.
I just tried to look for those little details
in the original product."
Rounding out Luffy's Straw Hat Pirates crew
are Mackenyu, the son of martial arts movie
legend Sonny Chiba, as the master swordsman
Zoro.
Emily Rudd, who played Clara in Amazon's "Hunters,"
appears as the enigmatic thief and navigator Nami.
Taz Skylar, who you might remember as Walt
in TNT's "The Lazarus Project," plays the
womanizing chef Sanji.
Rounding out the Straw Hats is Jacob Romero
Gibson, who played AJ Delajae in OWN's "Greenleaf,"
as the skilled marksman Usopp.
Supporting additions to the cast include Peter
Gadiot as Luffy's idol Red-Haired Shanks,
McKinley Belcher III as the villainous fishman
Arlong, Ilia Isorelýs Paulino as ruthless
pirate Alvida, and Jeff Ward as the clown-dressing
captain Buggy.
We'll also see Steven Ward as the fearsome
swordfighter Mihawk, Chioma Umeala as Nami's
adoptive older sister Nojiko, and Morgan Davies
as cabin boy and future Navy captain Koby.
It has been confirmed that the first two episodes
of "One Piece" Season 1 are directed by Marc
Jobst, who has some history with shows about
pirates, having helmed a Season 4 episode
of "Black Sails."
The Starz series, which ran for four seasons
between 2014 and 2017, is a prequel to "Treasure
Island" and is about pirates seeking riches
while evading the British government.
The themes are very similar, though there's
no superpowers in "Black Sails."
But that's not to say that Jobst doesn't have
experience in that area.
Jobst is perhaps best known for his work on
Netflix's hit "Daredevil" series, most notably
helming the Season 3 opener "Resurrection."
He also directed a couple of episodes of "Luke
Cage," meaning he has a shared history with
"One Piece" co-showrunner Matt Owens — Owens
was a staff writer and executive story editor
on the Marvel show.
Jobst is also known for directing episodes
of "The Witcher" and "Jupiter's Legacy," both
Netflix shows, so he's clearly trusted by
the higher-ups at the streamer.
Marty Adelstein, whose company Tomorrow Studios
helped get the live-action "One Piece" series
off the ground, is an executive producer on
the show, but fans will no doubt be more excited
to learn that "One Piece" creator Eiichiro
Oda is also producing.
When Oda was first approached about adapting
his long-running manga into a live-action,
English language series back in 2016, he had
some doubts.
Even after agreeing to the project, he had
some major reservations, as there were some
difficulties to begin with.
In a lengthy Instagram post, Oda wrote,
"We obviously come from very different cultures
so, when it comes to entertainment, we have
different codes, skill sets, and aims.
Sometimes it could be frustrating for both
sides.
It felt like, 'We're all trying to get to
the same place so how come we're not on the
same wavelength?'
There was even a time when I thought, 'Is
a foreign production even possible?!'"
Luckily, they were all able to get on to the
same page, taking the series in a direction
that Oda was happy with — the creator revealed
that he had, and still has, the final say
when it comes to what goes into the Netflix
show.
He wrote,
"They've promised they won't launch until
I'm satisfied.
They're burning with passion, and I've reminded
everyone involved that this should be fun."
Returning voice cast
In what was perhaps the most exciting announcement
at Anime Expo 2023, it was confirmed that
the voice cast from the long-running "One
Piece" anime series will be playing their
respective characters in the Japanese dub
of Netflix's live action show.
In a clip shared at the convention, Iñaki
Godoy revealed that he recently took a trip
to Tokyo to meet the original voice of Luffy,
Mayumi Tanaka.
Tanaka has been playing Luffy since 1999,
so, as a fan, Godoy was understandably very
excited to meet her.
"Luffy and you inspire me to be the best version
of myself that I can be.
I'm just so honored to meet you."
It seems like Tanaka was proud of of the new
Luffy actor, too, since she presented him
with a straw hat as a gift, telling him,
"I leave this hat with you.
Bring it to me someday once you've become
a great pirate."
Showrunners Matt Owens and Steven Maeda wrote
the first and last episode of Netflix's "One
Piece," entitled "Romance Dawn" and "Worst
in the East."
Maeda is perhaps best known as one of the
producers of "Lost," but he has plenty of
other noteworthy credits to his name, including
"Lie to Me" and "Helix."
He also wrote more than 40 episodes of "The
X-Files" between 2000 and 2002.
Matt Owens was a staff writer and executive
story editor on "Daredevil," but that's not
the only Marvel show he's been involved in
— he was also a writer on "Luke Cage," "Agents
of SHIELD," and "The Defenders."
The other writers involved in "One Piece"
have worked on shows like the animated "Harley
Quinn" series, "Supergirl," and "Umbrella
Academy," so it seems like the humorous, super-powered
antics of the manga and anime will be in good
hands.
When Netflix released the second trailer,
the streamer shared some words from "One Piece"
creator Eiichiro Oda.
In a note that was posted to Twitter, Oda
said that he fully expected fans of the source
material to highlight the differences between
the manga and the live-action show.
"After the launch, I'm sure I'll hear about
some people pointing out how this character
is missing or that scene is omitted, or this
bit is different from the manga.
But I'm sure they'll come from a place of
love, so I intend to enjoy even those comments!"
As Oda predicted, most of the early comments
were good natured, with fans on the whole
accepting that some changes need to be made
when it comes to creating something in real life.
One Reddit user wrote,
"I definitely see some changes to the plot.
Arlong's crew seems to show up at the Baratie,
Buggy's crew seems to have an actual circus
going on, plus it seems like the Going Merry
encounters Garp's ship at one point.
Everything still looks really good though!"
You'll never please everyone when it comes
to adapting a beloved manga series, but the
live-action "One Piece" seems to have plenty
of support from the fandom when it comes to
making tweaks — of course, having Oda on
board certainly helps.